the first foreign language I learned for
fun and not at school was Modern Hebrew
years later when I started studying
Indonesian I noticed that some
Indonesian words were similar to Hebrew
words for example Aon which means last
resembles Indonesian which means endam
which means World resembles Indonesian
Alam meaning nature in other words the
natural world kban which means victim
resembles the Indonesian word for
victim misen which means poor as in poor
thing like you feel sorry for someone
resembles Indonesian mkin which means
poor but in terms of money why would
there be Hebrew words in Indonesian well
they're not actually Hebrew they're
Arabic words but because Hebrew and
Arabic are both Semitic languages some
words are similar Arabic words were
borrowed into the Malay language because
of contact with Arab traitors and the
spread of Islam to the region Indonesian
is an offshoot of the Malay language